So, I want to analyze Artemis 2 because
I don't I'm not buying it, man. And
what's awesome is I'm starting to see
that the rest of the world isn't buying
it as well. There are so many people
waking up.
I I want to show you the reactions,
actually. I want to show you the
reactions from people who are seeing
that we're supposedly going to space,
supposedly going to the moon. Check this
out.
Literally, check this out. Artemis 2
crew captures stunning image of Earth
from Orion spacecraft on historic lunar
journey. This was posted by Benny
Johnson. And I want you to notice
there are 5,000 reactions. Look at the
most popular reaction.
The most popular
reaction is a laughing face.
There's only 399
hearts.
Almost 3,000
laughing faces, and there's even an
angry face and a crying face.
This is insane. Actually, if you added
up all these emojis, they would not add
up to the laughing.
Isn't that insane?
Uh 1.8 thousand thumbs ups.
Less than 400 hearts.
Yeah, it literally you get
like 200 and 2,500
positive reactions versus nearly 3,000
laughing emojis. I'm loving it. And look
at some of these comments. Space may be
the final frontier, but it's made in a
Hollywood basement with 86 reactions to
that. I thought they said it wasn't a
perfect circle, slightly pear-shaped. Uh
no stars in sight.
They got AI now. Which continent is that
exactly? Uh the math isn't mathing. So,
you guys you guys got to just rejoice
and celebrate that people are being
skeptical of NASA.gov, the government
agency.
I want to point out something very very
interesting when they were doing the
launch.
This is straight from uh let me show
you. This is straight from C-SPAN.
And notice what is going on here. This
is
Can I zoom in on this? Look at that.
Why is the part that's touching the
hottest part of the rocket
some kind of inflatable?
As they're moving the
engines back and forth, the thrusters,
and this whole thing is just starting
I'm starting to ask questions about the
rocket itself.
You know, I I already don't believe that
they're going to space. I don't believe
space travel is real. I don't believe
anyone has ever been to the moon. I
don't believe anyone's going to the moon
right now. I believe that there is a
major deception upon the rise. But um
I'm really starting to ask questions
about the actual rocket itself. Is this
thing really
4.3 million pounds as they say? I'm not
sure if that's how much this one
weighed, but that's what they said the
first Artemis weighed. I think it was
Artemis.
Could this
rocket actually be a zeppelin?
This thing looks just as rigid
and smooth as that rocket. Be honest
with yourself. Think outside the box. If
I just showed you this at an angle and
you didn't know what it was,
you would think that
this was a solid, rigid missile, right?
I could buy that. I could buy that this
thing was solid and metal, but it is
full of helium. It floats in the air.
Now, imagine if you had it upright with
some bottle rockets attached to the
side, and between the helium and the
bottle rockets, this thing goes flying
up into the air
while everybody's watching.
Now, I know that sounds absolutely
crazy. A friend of mine, David Weiss, he
actually did a video on this
6 years ago, where he was pointing out
an interesting phenomenon while the
rocket boosters are being lit, you see
some little sparklers going off, and
then the I guess the fuel is coming out
of these
uh thrusters.
And there's this odd bounce.
Notice just by the thrusters getting
ignited,
4 and 1/2 million pounds lifts up and
comes back down.
4 and 1/2 million pounds lifted up just
because of a little bit of a thrust.
Right? When when we see this thing go
off, it takes a lot of power to lift it
off the ground, but just when the
thrusters
were ignited, you see this little
bounce. It lifts up a little bit and it
comes back down.
I got questions, man.
And then I looked up
what organization is the largest single
user of helium? Based on historical
usage data, NASA
has traditionally been considered one of
the single largest consumers of helium,
primarily for purging liquid hydrogen
tanks and pressurizing rocket fuel
systems.
Very, very interesting. Are you guys
following? Like, I'm not making any
solid claims here, but that is
very interesting. And then I I saw this,
too. Uh
Artemis
2 helium. I ran across this moments ago.
What broke on Artemis 2? Helium system
fault after perfect rehearsal. Yeah,
helium issues. This is on SpaceX
community.
Helium issue leak.
on um issue with
with the SM prop uh in terms of
pressurization. So, we have helium that
pressures pressurizes the propellant
tanks, basically pushes out the oxidizer
and the fuel in order to make some of
the major burns.
Guys, I got questions, man.
So, what we just saw was some
weird, soft, balloon-looking textures
above the thrusters.
Uh we compared it to a zeppelin that
looks rigid.
You can't detect that this, you know,
think about the the floats at a parade.
They're big, they're rigid. They They
could take off in a moment.
The zeppelin looks hard and rigid like a
rocket.
And just so happens that NASA is the
world's largest consumer of helium.
So, what does this mean? This means that
NASA, the word the Hebrew word to mean
deceive, beguile, lead astray,
is
launching balloons up into the sky,
telling us that there's a whole crew in
there, and that they're on their way to
the moon.
So, when you watch live from NASA's
official YouTube channel, this is what
you see.
And they're saying that this is Earth.
That that's the terminator line. It
looks like a crescent moon. It looks
like a
an eclipse,
but they're saying that's Earth from
space right now.
And if you keep watching,
eventually
this is this is what you see.
For hours.
Just blue screen.
So, in 1969, you can live stream from
the moon with a VHS camcorder,
and no wires.
In in 1969,
when
Nixon could call the moon with a
landline, and and the people on the moon
could use a a big VHS camcorder and live
stream
live stream to the world. But But now,
in 2026, you know, everybody likes to
throw that at Man, this is 2026. You
still believe this and that. They act
like, Oh, we're in the the future,
right? You can't live stream without
getting a blue screen for hours.
I got questions, guys. I don't trust
these organizations. I don't trust what
they're saying. And like we saw this
image that they gave us,
and this is the Detroit News. They're
showing
this is an image. They're saying this is
an image here that was given to us
by Artemis.
And then you scroll down, and you'll see
this image.
It looks just like the other one, but
it's dark.
And when you compare them side by side,
so this is the image.
You see some green up here, this
uh nebula What is that called? The uh
the northern lights. And you see it
going on down here. You see
I guess this is the sun on the other
side,
but we're seeing the Earth illuminated
with even a hot spot here. What is this
hot spot?
How is this How does the Earth have a
hot spot when
the sun is in the background? I'm
guessing that's the moonlight.
And you can see some lights here on this
nation. You see a couple little stars
here. And then there's this image.
Now, I don't know if these are supposed
to be in taken hours apart. I read that
it was something about the aperture on
the camera,
but it seems like they're showing us
these images saying, Oh, look, there's
Here's one at nighttime. Here's one at
daytime. I don't know. I'm not going to
make any large leap, but these are the
exact same image. You can see that the
clouds have not moved. Look at Look at
this image here. Look at this formation
of the clouds. It's kind of like a S
shape.
And look right here. You still see this
S shape formation. So,
maybe maybe they did just take a picture
like this and they're like, "Oh, this is
Earth in the darkness of space.
Even though I can still see some detail.
And here's when we adjust the aperture.
Whoa, like you can see everything
in the darkness of space, which is
really interesting because
in one of these images, this is what
they show. This is how Earth looks in
the darkness of space.
Pitch black.
I'm not seeing one light. I mean, I
guess this is the ocean, so maybe
there's no lights here.
But it's just I'm not seeing any detail
on Earth.
They're They're telling you that this
isn't something blocking the lens. This
is the terminator line of darkness on
one side of Earth and the sun on the
other side. But yet somehow
in this image on the dark side of Earth,
you can see all the detail that they
could actually pick up by adjusting the
aperture.
I don't know, guys. You let me know what
you think in the comments. This is
crazy. I got questions. I'm not buying
it. I'm I'm like these other 3,000
people that are reacting with the
laughing face. I'm not buying it. I'm
not This is a clown show, but the the
big the biggest thing is is this is a
deception. We can laugh about it. We can
act like, "Oh, these These guys are
clowns." But this is serious.
These people are liars. They're
deceivers. They're thieves. They're
stealing your money because this is a
government agency that gets
a lot of money. I I can look it up if
you want to see the actual numbers, how
much money
does NASA get per
day?
And you'll see here it's
uh roughly 25 to 26 billion dollar
annual, uh 71 million dollars per day.
71 million dollars every single day of
your hard-earned cash.
And it's going towards what?
Deception.
Saying that there's people on a rocket
flying into outer space and we're
exploring and we're going to set feet on
the moon again.
Guys, we are living in the age of
deception. It was the first thing Jesus
said when they said, "What will be the
sign of your coming?" He said, "Let no
man deceive you. Let no man deceive
you." What's happening? We know there is
deception on the rise. Chris Bledsoe is
saying that the lady, this spiritual
being, told him that Easter 2026, which
is in uh
two or three days, there's going to be
some kind of
pivotal shift
in humanity
that aliens are going to be disclosed
and our whole world is going to change.
Now, I'm not saying I put my trust in
spiritual beings, but I think that Satan
has a plan. And so far, everything seems
to be lining up
with what Chris Bledsoe said this spirit
told him, the alignment of the stars and
a
uh a a full moon and alien disclosure is
being talked about like crazy right now.
And we just so happen to have people
going to the moon. Is this
moon mission part of setting
the stage for the grand delusion that's
about to happen?
You guys let me know in the comments. I
want to hear from you. If you like this
video, please give it a thumbs up.
Really helps this video get out into the
algorithm. Helps this channel to grow.
It's a free and easy way to support this
ministry. If you would like to donate to
this ministry so that we can keep
putting out videos like this to keep you
in the know of what's coming and what's
going on right now, you can go to
canatruth.org. We got Cash App, Venmo,
Zelle, PayPal. If you would like some
cool merch, we got some cool merch on
our website. We get about $5 per sale on
shirts, hoodies, mugs, all those things.
And it makes this ministry possible. We
actually also get invitations to go
around. We just uh are finishing up a
week of prayer in Alabama. Tomorrow's
the last day. We've been helping kids
build a community garden and giving
presentations with them. And we just
we've been going like crazy, guys. We
just got back from Guatemala getting
some footage that we still need to edit.
And we're doing it all for you guys. So,
if you want to support this ministry, if
you feel led to, we cannot thank you
enough. We can't do this without you
guys. And we'll see you next time on Can
of Truth.